ah désolé pour ce groupe de femmes
et c'est une femme qui a vendu aux
ennemis de base la situation animée très intense
mais avec beaucoup de
tension sexuelle et elles ont un homme et comment cela
affecte la loi donc c'était amusant d'essayer
de vraiment attirer l'attention  puis-je
vous offrir quelque chose en 20 vendu que vous soyez ici
a un effet esthétique c'est
tellement beau c'est tout à fait comme Sofia
filme elle a visualisé chaque image et
c'est sans aucun doute le film le plus
esthétiquement riche que je pense
qui fait partie de Sophia  est la
femme la plus classe,
je pense que tout le monde fait un si bon travail d'
équipe et tout le monde parce qu'ils aiment
tellement Sophia, elle veut vraiment
s'assurer que tout le monde est heureux et passe un
bon moment sur son plateau, c'est toujours très
confortable et tout le monde est si gentil et
tout le monde veut  être là parce qu'ils
veulent être là, elle
rassemble vraiment les bonnes énergies des gens et des
membres de la distribution, je pense que sa vision prend
naturellement vie, c'est juste une
ambiance vraiment détendue  vironment, elle est
incroyablement facile à vivre et juste
généreuse envers sa quarantaine Donny
belle astucieuse, passionnante et amusante, nous
demandons votre protection sur le mont doré, nous sommes
ravis que nous soyons tenus à l'écart de la maison
tout au long de ce soir l'histoire de ce
groupe de femmes qui ont été coupées dans
le  le monde n'a pas côtoyé un homme et
ils ne sont qu'un soldat blessé
qu'ils prennent est l'ennemi frappe comme la
combustion lente c'est le ménage étrange
qui commence à se dérouler et il
se libère devient intense il y a ces
femmes qui peuvent être piégées dans  cette maison
enfin ils ont cet homme mais il pense
qu'il peut nous déjouer je n'ai jamais
rencontré une pièce aussi délicate utérus
chérie attends nous ne proposons pas de
divertir tu les trouveras facilement si ça
commence comme un fantasme et puis
se transforme en un pire cauchemar exigeant
et oui, il y a beaucoup de tension sexuelle, nous
pouvons leur montrer une véritable
hospitalité du sud d'une manière, nous sommes aussi comme des
sorcières, je pense que j'espère que vous aimez
la tarte aux pommes, c'est que  ma recette c'est que ces
femmes détiennent le pouvoir dans la situation
j'espère que ça va être effrayant intense va
au fumoir prends le cou de l'âme
porte le sur moi ta fidèle
chienne